dernier essai avant le jour j les
passionnés du train finalisent leur
installation 50 mètres carrés de réseaux
ferroviaires entièrement créés par ce
club de modélisme un loisir partagé par
32 adhérents aux compétences variées
on a besoin de faire de la menuiserie de
la peinture électricité de lektronix
suivant les compétences de chacun nous
ne sommes pas limités à comme dans
certains clubs à une époque particulière
à une région particulière donc chacun
amène ses trains dont cabillaud tout du
tout type des ter des vapeurs voilà qui
est plutôt une installation visibles les
17 et 18 mars lors d'une exposition
commune avec les amis des flots
l'association de modélisme naval cette
fois à l'initiative de ce projet ces
passionnés mettre plusieurs mois voire
plusieurs années pour réaliser leur
bateau j'ai fabriqué de toutes pièces
l'ensemble du bateau ce n'est pas la
sienne pas une boîte de construction il
a fait que je découpe les morceaux de
bois travaillé entre autres la résine
par exemple à la dérive un futur voilier
télécommandé qui ne sera pas exposée
mais les visiteurs pourront tester
d'autres créations similaires moi j'aime
bien avoir mes bateaux naviguent et
ensuite nous avons un bassin pour
pouvoir faire une initiation avec les
enfants ou les parents d'ailleurs
d'après télé radio commande
ils feront naviguer sur le petit bassin
qu'on leur mettra à disposition de quoi
devenir capitaine ou voyager en wagon le
temps d'une journée sans quitter les
yvelines